good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
tuesday how's everyone doing i'm doing
pretty good considering this is a
tuesday for most of you but for us it's
the last show of the week so it's pretty
exciting to
know that alarm free living is coming
our way you're going on vacation but for
me i get to sleep in my own bed alarm
free which
is such a treat you know happy for you
so also today is like a beautiful fall
day in new york and i'm just it's really
not it's so straining this morning
stunning outside for sure it's stunning
there's a chill in the air you know
that's the kind that we that sweeps away
all the bad smells by the way like okay
so we're on like
what's the word like opposite paths like
you're being so positive this morning
like and that was me like two weeks ago
i'm in the worst [ __ ] mood today like
i just got my period right before my
trip which is just so annoying having no
worse okay you woke me up a million
times in the middle of the night can i
help you turn it around sure so you got
your period right before your trip which
is actually great because you drop that
bloat like really quickly it's better
than getting your period in the middle
of the trip and then the first few days
you're bloated because you only lose
time because you're like that because
you're about to get your period okay
sure like i don't really care about you
i'm bloated consistently like i don't
see the difference you really don't like
feel a little bit lighter when you when
your period drops you want to know a fun
fact about me i've never been bloated
like in or or i've never been uploaded i
don't know people are always like i'm so
bloated i'm like oh really i'm just fat
like i don't know what bloated is i
agree with that like i never say i'm so
bloated like unless i literally ate like
my body weight and salt like i can't
imagine actually feeling like so bloated
but i do always feel like a little
before my period comes then once it
comes i do feel a drain and they don't
feel that no
no i don't think it would make a
difference that's
okay okay so that one doesn't work for
you so now we're getting cramps now can
you just let me complain please like
we're going to turn your frown upside
down turn it around turn around
[Music]
turn it upside you know this made me
feel better you know i think the
triangle counts as percussion
literally of course literally it's a
percussion instrument right
um so thea woke you up throughout the
night because he just wanted you to know
that he was there because he was going
to miss you he wanted to spend extra
time together let me tell you i couldn't
sleep and i'm like tossing turning
tossing turning finally i drift i'm like
there i'm like
70 like you know about to just yeah what
your thoughts stop making sense and then
someone's standing on my back
and it's [ __ ] theo and he wanted to
get under the covers which is sweet but
like you could do it yourself so he let
him in and then i was up that was up
talked to ben watching tick tocks like
it was just no going back and then i
didn't go to bed to like two
oh and then i woke up with my period
like i feel as i'm trying me i've been
i've earned my bad mood okay fine fine
and then you had cramps you said of
course did you take my doll i took i
took advil big mistake no i know you
like
sung the praises of middle for so long
and then like earlier this year i was
like all right let me [ __ ] with my doll
and to be honest i felt no difference no
i think my doll is so great it's so
targeted you know to the cramped needs
that's what you had said plus it has a
little caffeine that's what you had said
as well so okay but you know what
different strokes for different folks
i'm sorry you're feeling this way
me too things happen
they do we've got an menstruating queen
and a pregnant queen this room is just
radiating with different hormones yes
quite different hormones but back to
what i was saying i think it's quite a
good day especially considering it's our
last show of the week so we have so much
love and energy to give in to the show
and like yesterday was the most chaotic
day on the planet
i know it was so chaotic we recorded the
redheads it was crazy
no instagram was down facebook was down
whatsapp was down like if you if you
live in israel like that's the only
people i know who use whatsapp and like
the morning toast didn't upload the
video until much later in the day
because i um
had to edit something out that i had
said it wasn't bad or anything it was
just like too personal if you know what
i'm saying yeah um and the youtube
platform like if you want to take it up
with youtube that's on them it took they
can get hours just to edit out one thing
they can get their processing done
faster so that was my fault today i'm
going to try and not say anything stupid
over share i mean i've already spoken
about my period so i don't know how much
more i could share right
right today we're going to be on time
yesterday was crazy we'll talk about the
outage it's obviously a story it was the
biggest story of the day i want to know
how it affected you i mean i've never
been so unbelievably bored in my whole
[ __ ] life really but also like i did
a bunch of things yesterday like i had
put off doing i don't think i did it
consciously like you know instagram's
down let me be productive but i like
needed to do something with my hands and
i have all these flights i've been
needing to book i have so many weddings
coming up all over the country i'm just
like such a globe saturn
and i did a lot of things that i haven't
done in a while so maybe that was good
but like overall i was just bored to
tears
i understand and then like i did an
instagram story when we were back i'm
like thank god i've been so bored and
people are like that's so sad like
normalize being obsessed with instagram
[ __ ] off i think being obsessed with
instagram has been normalized i think
it's weird that people said that's so
sad considering everybody was like
posting stuff like that yesterday
i just went i don't know what i did with
my day yesterday but i really didn't
notice it's because i was like napping i
was chilling with brew
it was still down i was like not
pressed about it and then around like
five o'clock when i was like going to
the redheads i was like oh that's crazy
it's still it's down like it's been a
down day i didn't really realize right
it started being down the second we
wrapped the toast like i had posted a
story that i remember that is that never
went through but then i got home i was
chilling with brew it was down and then
by the time i like a few hours later i
realized it was still down i was like oh
this is a big deal but it really didn't
impede my day
no it didn't impede my day i was just
[ __ ] bored it actually did impede
something because
we recorded the redheads last night but
we weren't able to get questions from
the readers
so we don't have any redhead questions
but we have lots of dbqs um from the
readers
the book club guide so it's a really
great episode we recapped a slow fire
burning by paula hawkins it drops on
thursday so that's just another day
where you don't have to go podcast lists
even though we are ooo so just really
quickly one more thing i wanted to say
about the facebook and instagram outage
like you'll have the time to talk about
it as well it's a story it's a story
okay so you know i'll save my hot take
yeah because we're going to talk about
what happened there what we know what we
don't know which is probably everything
and what it means for society
for sure
we also have dear toasters today great
big day here
and i caught up on only murders
i'm caught up except for yesterday's
episode oh yesterday yeah they come out
tuesday is today tuesday yeah oh it just
came out at today i have to say like
this whole dropping weekly thing is so
not conducive for my lifestyle i know
like i thought that the show was over
and i got down to watch like so many
episodes last night it was like eight
o'clock and it was done because episodes
are really short yep and there was like
only four like i thought it was
and it's just getting good like yeah no
it's really good
yeah it's really good so i'm obsessed
and i do think like if you think one of
them should win an emmy or like you know
it's being acclaimed as like the best
show this year so of course people are
going to be nominated okay who because
like honestly steve martin and martin
short are competing for the same
category who do you think out of the
three of them should get nominated and
who should win
i think they'll all obviously get
nominated because if it's the best show
and they're the stars then they made it
the best show
who should win i don't
i know you don't like him my least
favorite martin short 100 he's giving it
all to the show he was being so funny i
can't believe you don't like him like he
is whoever wrote this character for
assault so on point from like like a
retired broadway like failed producer
his one-liners i turned on the uh the
subtitles because i felt like i was
missing some of his jokes he that
character is so funny i can't believe
you don't like him i don't dislike him
anymore i just like really didn't like
how he was like being sneaky and he had
mismanaged like his life and then he was
like trying to sell this podcast but now
that everyone's above board and spoiler
like between the three of them there's
really no secrets anymore i i like him
more i agree with that i just don't like
when you're like hiding stuff and you're
gonna bring the rest of the group down
with you i couldn't agree more but you
know there was one low point
um
in the show
and that was when we had to like see
selena gomez's fake mom like
inspire her like with her art like it
was so dark i'm like this is like the
show so far has been a plus 10 out of 10
elevated classic and this was giving me
very much like the mom from wizards of
waverly place vibes like i was really
surprised like that whole scene was like
i was watching a different show and then
i went back to city and everything was
back to normal i actually agree that was
the first time where i was like oh
selena gomez is in this yeah right right
like this is the first time i was like
where's my phone you know gotta check
what's going on it was so boring yeah no
but the show itself is really good and
the most recent episode that i watched
was from the perspective of theo by the
way yeah love to see it no his name is
teddy his dad's theo no i think teddy's
short for theo
teddy is the dad you know but they're
named after each other teddy is the dad
theo's the son okay okay yeah um and
he's deaf and so the whole episode was
from his perspective so there wasn't
very much sound which was actually
really cool it was really cool
i was scared watching it like the
silence was freaking me out maybe
because i was home alone and it was dark
but like it wasn't a scary episode per
se i was i know i think i watched it
like
at dusk on the couch got it like the
silence was giving me like creepy ass
vibes
interesting but i thought it was a very
unique take to represent someone who's
deaf yeah i could see that episode like
being nominated so totally i've not seen
anything like that me neither and it was
just it's such a good show like i was
actually so devastated when i ran out of
episodes but i guess there's another one
today and then did theo feel seen
because
he's theo because his namesake yes he
did in the book that we just read
there's a character theo you know what
the more i ruminate on it the more i
regret naming theo theo because like my
future son's name should be theo it's a
gorgeous [ __ ] name i think you could
still name your kid theo because it's
one thing to name a dog after a person
that's a no
but it's i think it's nice to name a
person after a dog i would actually
argue that it's worse no no no but think
about little craig
disgusting that's disgusting that's the
worst
like here's this dog i'm naming it after
you no i i think honestly they're both
pretty pretty shitty no i don't i think
that like upgrading the dog's name to a
human like the dog it's only good things
for the dog well the good thing is
inside my period and i don't have to
think about that right now
i'm just saying like if you wanted to
one day you have my support you're open
to it yeah it's theo you have to talk to
it's a
gorgeous name no it's gorgeous and think
of that you get the nickname you get
theodore you get ceo and you get teddy
you know what my i've had like this
renaissance with my kindle like i had
was on like a six-month break and i was
just reading so many books and you know
if you're pregnant
or like thinking about becoming pregnant
or like adopting and you're thinking of
child names like read books like i found
so many random [ __ ] names and i'm
like that's pretty i definitely do read
like looking for names i haven't
seen anything via book
but yeah no also when i'm watching um tv
like i'm always thinking like looking at
everyone's names now yeah but like
honestly i could go through a whole
tv show and not know the main characters
names like what the [ __ ] is martin
schwartz's name
that's a really good question and in the
book like their first name comes up so
many times like you have to remember it
that's a really good question yeah i
know his name is brazos but what's his
real name another really good you're
asking all the hard questions i know
mabel because that's like an odd name
and everyone's like mabel this label
that like they're right maybe
everything's about maple yeah so what
are the two main characters its names i
don't know i don't know if we'll ever
know we could look it up but i'd rather
not know and also like i went through
watching all of squid games not knowing
one person's name because like you're
not allowed to say your name in the
squid game um but then like they shared
it at the end but like
i couldn't remember
that sounds kind of annoying yeah but um
i just love only murders like i just i
can't really stress enough how i'm like
obsessed with the show no i might
re-watch it after like so good and i'm
sure you'll pick up new things it's
really really good and of course it pays
respect to podcasts and the art of
podcasting and i feel seen i don't know
about you hundred percent and
i keep waiting for this one particular
scene because they filmed right outside
my building and i was like what show is
selena gomez doing with martin short i
was so confused because honestly when
you think about it like without knowing
what the show is like what the [ __ ] like
it's so random and i'm just waiting for
them to be shooting outside my building
oh that's pretty cool i haven't seen it
yet it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
you know actually i watched yesterday's
episode and it was amazing obviously no
complaints um actually just one like
when we were doing our final story like
you really cannot hear the triangle when
we go like this like we need to be like
this oh but
i when we do final story are you able to
hear your ad living at the end obviously
okay but i think i could hear my
ad-libbing at the end in china i think
it's because my voice is too loud no the
triangle is fur there are way i think
it's good the way the triangle is all
triangle content i've seen has been
really premium
okay
okay do you think that without further
ado we should just
jump right in
oh my god first i know that you don't
know what that hand motion is
referencing it's referencing a dive into
the water to reference or not reference
but there's this woman on tiktok who's a
former sex worker and she shares like
the craziest [ __ ] stories and she
always uses this song feels like i'm
going insane yeah
it's a thief in the night to come and
grab you and she does the same three
hand motions but she's telling different
crazy like stories that happened to her
and she always does that it'll creep up
inside you and consume you so that's
what you're doing
i can't wait for tick tock to go down
never
never
that's what we need why jackie you're
literally the star of my tick tock
follow me a girl with no job it's true
it's true like oh i literally do a tick
tock in the studio every day now because
the only ones that get likes are the
ones with jackie
why do you guys just comment that you
hate me like tacos are so sweet they're
so sweet no but i do think that like for
society and for nature to start healing
we need a day of tick-tock to go down
just for everyone to see
everything else they could be doing with
their life
hard disagree and you know what let's
just leave it at that okay well until we
talk about the first story in the last
five stories without further ado here
are the five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
that's oh bruce the best and most
affordable electric toothbrush on the
market if you've been thinking about
switching over to electric toothbrushes
which you definitely should for all the
hygienic benefits um you know that a lot
of them can cost over 200 which is just
unreasonable in my opinion but that's
where bruce comes in the most affordable
electric toothbrush on the market and in
my opinion the most styling while in
living it up in the city the brush comes
with four unique modes to customize the
brushing experience the battery life
lasts four weeks and it also comes with
a magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case that i will be taking on my
trip tomorrow they also have a
subscription program so you never forget
to change your brush head they'll ship
you a new replacement head every six
months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head their electric
toothbrush has modern aesthetically
pleasing designs and they come in trend
driven seasonal colors they look great
on your bathroom counter if you want to
get 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit and
the refill plan use promo code toast at
bruce.com toast that's 15 off using
promo code toast at
dot com brush.com toast bruce dot com
slash toast use code toast thank you
claudia
it's a pleasure
okay first story biggest story facebook
is back up after being down for many
hours yesterday the outage likely cost
the company over 60 million dollars in a
major outage yesterday facebook along
with its sibling sites whatsapp and
instagram became unreachable for hours
starting around noon eastern time about
the time that the toast wrapped mm-hmm
reports are saying that it was directly
correlated to the toast ending
um but we can either confirm or deny
those neither confirmed nor deny and i
guess facebook servers and systems are
so incestuous that people who work in
the facebook offices couldn't even get
into the buildings to fix ship because
their key cards weren't working because
it was the whole thing was down okay
like
this is supposed to be like the most
technologically advanced company
in the world not even in the country
like in the world and these people can't
even get to their desks like
i don't know
fishy yeah no it was it was definitely
wild i don't know if it'll ever sound
like a conspiracy i don't know if you'll
ever know what happened
but something ain't right no i don't
want to sound like a conspiracy theorist
but i have a few things i'd just like to
point out as someone who's completely
non
unbiased third party with no particular
interest in the matter okay i don't know
if you have no interest in the matter
considering like if you know what i mean
so first of all i'm constantly hearing
about like you know how facebook is down
instagram is down all the time i never
hear that about twitter or tick tock or
reddit or pinterest so why is this
company always having issues when
they're also technically the most
successful in the space like they should
have the most infrastructure so that
things like this don't happen so it's
like very common for instagram to be
down i literally go to twitter i search
his instagram down and everyone's
commiserating on twitter like it happens
a lot
why is that
no other nobody else has that problem i
don't know
maybe there have too many users but also
i think
i don't know i i i'm not going to
purport to know but based on what i was
seeing yesterday it's like
instagram facebook and whatsapp all
use the same server so like it's like
domino's when this [ __ ] happens yeah i
just don't understand why it does happen
so frequently like of course i'm an
understanding consumer some a bad day at
the office
something goes down whatever but this
happens like all the time with instagram
yeah but to be real would you know if
pinterest were down i definitely would
i'm pinning all the time okay i'm just
saying so maybe pinterest goes down
maybe reddit goes down but like you
don't know i really don't feel like they
do and i feel like if they did it would
be at least like trending on twitter
people would be talking about it like
i've literally never seen that
yeah well i think a lot of times
instagram goes down but then it comes
back up in like 30 minutes yeah so this
was about at least six hours
and it took all the other well i'm sorry
facebook took all the other apps down
with it so this was i think the largest
scale one that we've seen yes i don't
think i've ever experienced an instagram
downage that also took facebook with it
and from what i've seen they're saying
that like they accidentally lock
themselves out like someone just
accidentally sent to the server like
we're out and
it took everything they had to go
they like locked the keys in the car and
they didn't have a spare key that's what
i saw
but like anyone getting hacky vibes no
and also like you don't spare kate
yeah your facebook i don't know it just
like seems a little hacky out to me well
here's the thing that really bothered me
about this whole situation
it's kind of like the narrative i was
seeing afterwards like making fun of
influencers like oh my god like when
you're all your influencers freaking out
like that they couldn't like sell you
lipstick okay like what if i came to
your office and snapped your keyboard
over my leg like that's your job you
would be freaking out that you couldn't
do your job to put food on the family
for your [ __ ]
fit
food on the table for your [ __ ]
family food on the family for i would
love that food on the table for your
family like i just hate this like oh my
god probably influencers like crying
thinking they're gonna have to go get a
real job like first of all influencing
is a real job second of all like i don't
know why you refuse to understand that
like literally your job being instagram
is like not acceptable like that would
literally be like okay you're a dentist
and i walk into your dental practice and
i remove all the teeth
yeah is that funny to you sir doctor
it was just really pissing me off like
all these memes like making fun of like
first like well also okay i just also a
lot of businesses especially small
businesses rely on facebook and
instagram for sales advertising
promotion so like they all suffered
yesterday and an influencer or a creator
is just a business on a platform so like
you're really making fun of small
businesses right look at the mirror yeah
you're making fun of small businesses
you don't support other women or small
businesses
and women and male influencers too
sure
it felt very targeted towards women like
no i did like the content that i was
seeing like oh my god your favorite like
it was just very it was directed at
women i'm telling you like and i just
don't like this narrative
yeah because like i i guess i'm not like
a full-time influencer but i had the
greatest day yesterday so much peace
well we are full-time influencers but
our
business doesn't revolve around posting
on social media yeah no we're not
instagram influencers right we're
podcast influencers we're just like yeah
but that's what happens when you're
multi-platform call me when the podcast
app goes down even though i feel like
it's always down but see this is
actually
now i think was probably a wake-up call
for a lot of influencers who are very
like one platform focused like if your
entire business is built off of facebook
or just instagram um you got to be
multi-platform you know we were able to
communicate with not to rub it in to
communicate with our audiences on
different platforms podcasts i was up on
tick tock all day even though my
audience is not that big you got to have
more than one platform because in case
that goes down oh for me like i wasn't
able to communicate with anyone i would
just have to wait till the next day's
episode but like that worked for me yeah
but you have like people had heard from
us that day yes yeah i agree i don't yes
you could say like this should be a
wake-up call for people to diversify
their portfolios i don't think that's
what it's going to be no but like if
this had happened like five years ago
when like my whole business was just
like instagram i wouldn't like freaking
out yeah
especially if you were supposed to run
ads that day and then if you posted an
ad right before the outage it went down
and then like you lost six hours worth
of like conversions no and then it just
makes you think like
people always say this and it's never
gonna happen but like what if instagram
were to just like poof and disappear one
day and your whole business is like if
instagram were to disappear to like five
years ago for me i would literally have
to like go to grad school like i would
have to find another way of living and
now
if instagram would went down like i
would be bored but my business would
remain
somewhat unaffected yeah
yeah and so that's the lesson i took
away yeah and then if tick tock went
down
my soul would leave my body but my
business would be fine okay that's good
to hear i just really think they should
do tick-tock next because i did feel
like nature was starting to heal
yesterday so why don't you just call up
the hackers and let them know i you know
maybe they'll be making the rounds
maybe you know okay so whose picture did
you get stuck on elizabeth cevetsky and
wearing multiple barrettes and carrying
her child
mine was um
kate c parker she doesn't know kate is
still about bobby bones his wife she did
this like really sweet i could literally
recite the caption to you word for word
she did this sweet like you know
carousel of ins of photos from her
wedding talking about how like she was
she knew like how a man should treat her
because of her dad and as she got she's
gotten older she's really come to
appreciate that like she had such an
amazing father in her life
what a rough caption to get stuck for
you yesterday literally a 13th year
anniversary of my father's death
yesterday go to instagram and i'm
terrorized by caitlyn's gorgeous photos
of her and her happy alive father
damn it's tough
to think about and also it probably made
you more present in the day yesterday
and like more present in your
grief no i was i'm majorly in denial
yesterday i didn't think about it me too
i just honestly like wasn't in the mood
it'll hit me i don't i don't feel like
just because it's an anniversary of a
death or someone's birthday i have to be
sad that day you can't as what if i'm
not schedule grief no i'll get there
grief arrives on its own time i was just
not in the mood yesterday i'm like
instagram's down and now i have to cry
like i'll do it another time i'm going
on a plane tomorrow maybe i'll cry
tomorrow yeah no i feel that
wholeheartedly
i'm so glad you agree
and so yeah and then i didn't realize
that the stories at the top of
that were there were loaded yeah like
you could scroll through stories there
just wasn't new ones i didn't realize
that i didn't even watch them i watched
a few and then i was like
this is boring yeah no you had to just
go cold turkey yeah it was crazy it was
crazy i thought it was also very busy
yesterday yeah well you made yourself
useful yeah got it because instagram was
isn't this nail color like so not me
no it's pretty you it's still like
bridal
yeah this nail color is kind of you
love yeah dazzle dry
you love dazzle drive i do this one i
got
thursday
gorgeous and it's no chemicals it lasts
longer and um
dries really quickly are you allowed to
get manicures
pregnant i haven't seen anything to the
contrary but like i said no chemicals so
yeah i could just see like someone
saying like the chemicals from the
polishes into your nail buds into your
veins and go straight to your heart yeah
no i could see i'm sure someone does say
that yeah but this one's not chemicals
so
are you wearing deodorant while you're
pregnant big time organic or regular
men's
totally men's extra strength extra
aluminum there's just something that a
woman cannot do
that never even occurred to me no one
told me that i couldn't wear deodorant
no i don't think that's a thing but i
think a lot of people who are very
organic i'm not very organic i'm not and
i'm doing like i feel like i'm actually
force going a lot more than maybe i even
need to what are you foregoing i don't
know like
even like zofran for example like a lot
of people take zopan in pregnancy and i
just feel like i'm pushing through you
know that's very brave with you i mean i
took a dramamine for the car ride this
weekend and like that felt like a lot to
me
like the toxic
so i really i feel like
uh
hopefully i'm doing you just do what
feels right yeah nick caveman more nail
polish the cavemen were doing everything
no but the thing is like the caveman
didn't use deodorant i didn't get it
because it didn't exist it didn't have
parachutes you know what i'm saying they
used to smoke when they were pregnant oh
yeah oh if you want to go back to like
i'm just saying like we're going to be
20th century pregnancies we're going to
be fine
you would hope but then people also
lived to like they were 30 so
in the cavemen yeah yeah yeah
anyways are you ready for our next story
sure
rob kardashian is seen in a rare photo
as he enjoys a night out with the family
that just reminded me of something so
the kardashian clan united for dinner on
monday and rob made a rare appearance on
instagram kim shared a photo of her on a
date with her favorite couples including
courtney and travis and chloe and rob
lol okay you just reminded me of
something okay we have one more picture
to post in the feed should we take a
selfie no okay i'll just post something
post um
maybe something will come up okay okay
but like we have to do it before i know
i know i [ __ ] up because yesterday
instagram was down so i didn't get to
post till six then i posted at nine and
then i was like tired yeah no i
understand it's not your fault that
instagram was down but our feet's not
gonna suffer because of it no and
instagram doesn't care that our like
feed is ruined instagram doesn't care
about your feelings not at all nor your
feed um what were you saying oh rob he's
looking so good and cute first of all
loved the kravis moment on kim's
instagram like that was just kind of
crazy so they got grid prominence they
weren't buried in a photodump they got
grid prominence but like honestly
her brother and sister maybe should have
been first no when her instagram is so
curated that it's i thought it was like
such an endorsement
it's wild maybe they got engaged she
like one time deleted all of her
vacation photos because she wanted to
put a different filter on them that's
crazy and she's just out here posting
courtney and travis whose house is that
chris
um i don't know you think they just had
like a big family dinner with their chef
i feel like it's chloe's house because
she's the only one who would have things
like that in the back
what are those leaves
they're called like those white
influencer leaves yeah right
kim would not kim would never well okay
so
but no but chloe's in the news and chloe
have new homes so we wouldn't recognize
them
i don't think that this is kim's house
and it might be courtney's it might be
courtney's and courtney's been hosting a
lot she had that pooch pool party thing
well here the court is so fabulous
courtney has a purse if you had dinner
at your own home would you bring a purse
yes okay
if i was going to my backyard which was
expansive yeah you need chapstick i need
chapstick
oh in your purse yeah for sure
need a tampon
i do need a tampon thank you i'm trying
to read through the comments anyone's
like you know
mentioning where they are but no no no
did she post any stories
no okay well i guess we'll never know
gorgeous i'm sure we'll know one day you
know what actually i feel like i can
figure it out do you remember um we got
those aerial pics i hate the word ariel
our
what are you trying to say bird's eye i
know like finish yourself of chloe and
chris's new homes oh here
oh by the way that this is totally it
but you think it's totally finished with
all these twinkle lights and everything
that picture was like so recent it still
looks like a construction a month ago
that's true that's
and she has so much tchotchkes in the
background but i do want to say like a
lot of the finishes on this white home
that
tmz captured do look like the outside
that's just kardashian style i'm just
saying
it's not kim's style no it's not kim's
style it's possible oh wait you know
whose house this looks like
but she's just not in the pictures
kylie you know she has like that
outdoor indoor type she wouldn't do her
backyard like this she doesn't have
pompous like that
you know what
we need to put this to bed we need to
move on it's not literally that's not
the point i literally can't okay what's
the point the point is that rob is out
and about courtney kravis
chloe like it's all in the family and
they're just living life i'm sure they
were also filming for the show because
they just started filming again and so
you will find out one day and i saw a uh
like
kardashian fan page instagram account
putting up pictures of chris and
kylie
filming in a grocery store so that's
just
very exciting that is very exciting
highly
oh wow
maybe they can like finally afford her
you know right no i think that like as
much as kylie didn't need the money she
also like wasn't obsessed with the idea
of doing the show but now that it's like
a clean slate they probably have way
more money kylie's like something
that'll actually get kylie out of bed
and like she can get involved in the
creative process from day one like yeah
she was just a child with the kardashian
stuff so what do you think the show's
gonna be called
it could just be the kardashians like
they don't really need any bells and
whistles keeping up was always like
a long unnecessary name oh i couldn't
disagree more i thought it was like
perfectly branded like no but they made
it and they're really crazy but
k-u-w-t-k
yeah people just called it keeping up
which is so cute i thought it was a
great name nobody ever had anything
but it wasn't like it
it wasn't like it made the most sense
nothing will ever make sense like that
again oh no no i'm not saying that it's
a little long no no i'm not saying that
i just thought it was like a great name
and i never really like blinked at it
i'm like yeah that's keeping up like
the kardashians no i think whatever they
do next will show you that that name was
like it'll probably just be called like
a mouthful that name was in mouthful i
thought it was great i totally disagree
okay i'm not
i'm not gonna slander the good keeping
up with the kardashians names i don't
think i slandered it i think i just said
the truth which is that it's a mouthful
just because
does it being slender make it not true
yeah um yeah
got it okay um well i'm very very much
looking forward to this new show and
hulu is out here turning on premium
content like we must put respect on
hulu's name several nine perfect
strangers thank you are you ready for
our next story some exciting news that i
should have shared yesterday but i
totally forgot only if it's the next
story that's brought to you by uprising
food it is their mission is to liberate
all of us from the fundamentally broken
food system that's stealing our health
the real devil is the snowball effect of
silent inflammation and uprising foods
have cracked the coat on healthy bread
you simply can't find something this
healthy that tastes this good and that's
this fresh with only two net carbs per
serving six grams of protein and nine
grams of fiber they cover paleo to clean
keto to simple low carb to high fiber to
dairy free to grain free they've really
got it all covered and you know studies
show that the intake of high fiber foods
during pregnancy can lower the risk of
diabetes preeclampsia and constipation
jack so i know you've been loving your
uprising food bread
while you've been pregnant it all comes
down to taste and healthy foods are
littered with broken promises uprising
has nailed the taste factor on both
their sourdough-esque cubes and the
crunch factor on their newly launched
freedom chips with t which tastes like
those old school rye chips that you dig
for uprising is offering our listeners
ten dollars off the starter bundle that
includes two superfood cubes
and four pack of freedom chips to try go
to uprisingfood.com
toast and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout that's
u-p-r-i-s-i-n-g
food dot com slash toast to get 10 off
your first purchase of the starter
bundle check it out especially if you're
pregnant look into all the benefits that
high fiber
foods can have for you yes great stuff
okay next story the super bowl 2022
halftime show was announced like very
quietly very quietly it literally
slipped through the cracks yesterday but
we need to talk about it because either
not even yesterday i heard about it on
friday no but for yesterday's show we
didn't do a show friday i always am so
interested in like the acts and selected
in the selection process so i just find
it fascinating 2022 we will have a show
by snoop dogg eminem dr dre mary j blige
kendrick lamar
period period okay so it's it's a medley
of sorts it's a medley and i just
i'm anti-medley i'm sorry
i
my idea of a great super bowl halftime
show is one iconic artist if they choose
to surprise us with a gesture or two
that's fine but like i miss the days of
like this is the biggest artist of the
year like this is their moment i just
hear you said that like pink
was the next
well i should be the next i always think
she could be the next one i always think
pitbull could be the next one
um and i feel like any of these people
on their own could maybe be have been
the next one i just feel like it's it's
now turning into a music festival
and i like when it was just like the one
it's the biggest it becomes the biggest
deal for that performance it's a huge
honor i mean five lady gaga five for two
right like it's such an honor your music
just like
sells like hotcakes after and it's such
a mark of success it's like legends
category and the for the past few years
i mean last year was just the weekend
and so that is um that was good that
gives me what i was looking for this the
performance didn't but the performer the
choice the choice did but i do feel like
in the past few years it's been like
this medley and i'm anti-medley you know
what i do agree with you like because it
is this like one prestigious honor and
it's like fun to see who's gonna get it
every year and see how they do
um i completely agree with you i'm not
like the biggest medley fan
i'm so glad that we can agree and i'm
sure it will be great because all of
these people are legends but like they
could do the show on their own eminem
could do the halftime show on his own
kendrick lamar could yeah snoop dogg i'm
very much looking forward to and if mary
j blige doesn't sing doubt which has
become one of my favorites it's such a
good song but i feel like it's so
it's not you know it's like not high on
her hits list yeah but if you're ever
feeling like low on yourself
listen to that episode of toast radio
where did we put it in yeah we did oh i
think it was the theme for the toast
radio justice for toaster radio it was
like motivational songs it was
motivational because it was like january
episode so it's like these are the songs
they're gonna get you to like accomplish
your goals this month okay and doubt is
that song like she is the moment it's so
gorgeous like whenever i listen to it i
just i like want to go for a jog or
something like that that's the point
it's gorgeous check it out doubt by mary
j blige and i'm sure she won't sing it
because if it's a medley she probably
gets like two songs and i don't think
that's like her top two
but um
[Music]
so yeah that's why i'm just i feel like
whenever i hear the selection whether
it's a medley or an individual like i
talk [ __ ] i'll see the performance if i
like the performance then i'll think it
was a good good selection
i don't know i like to talk about the
selection and then the performance
because i thought the weekend was a
great selection then i thought his
performance was like very low energy
right so it's two totally different
conversations and then like when j lo
got it i was like pissed that shakira
got it too and then i thought i'm like
you know what this is actually pretty
fire agreed and if you had at the time i
would have said i i don't want a 50 50
show
i think that's unfair to like both
icons but they did a great job yeah
jayla could have done the whole thing so
could have shakira right
so it's just like it ain't right it
ain't right but i'll see how this turns
out and then you'll get my final verdict
but for now i'm very much like
why so many artists
yeah that's that's where i'm at too also
like the
performance was announced like with
pepsi and jay-z's rock nation because
he's like been in charge of like nfl
entertainment for which for like two no
not for a while for like two years
because the nfl was having a lot of
problems like getting black artists to
agree to do the super bowl because they
were having a lot of
issues and so i think that the jay-z
partnership was meant to be like a peace
offering to you know work together
and i guess it's working yeah no they're
definitely getting some interest now and
the super bowl is going to be in
englewood california at the sofie
stadium oh that's pretty cool yeah so if
you wanted to go who do you think will
be in the super bowl let's place our
best oh that's a good idea and then we
can okay
so can i look up the teams right now i
don't know like all their names and you
have to be from different categories oh
that's tough for me yeah at all nfl
teams
i don't know that i'll be able to do
different categories afc nfc
yeah those are them okay
so many good ones i think it's going to
be the seahawks
and the buccaneers is that a possibility
oh right the buccaneers
okay i'm gonna say
it's gonna be the buccaneers oh you know
i kind of have like a good call
oh here east west north and south
okay i think it's gonna be the
buccaneers
verse
the
buffalo bills is that possible
they're both east just based on the um
is that possible based on the country
layout he doesn't know
okay then i'll take it back i'll do the
what is it called buccaneers buccaneers
maybe do like the rams
okay here's the thing i'm looking at
this list of nfl teams and i don't even
see the buccaneers like what am i doing
wrong are you looking at cities or names
oh would it say tampa yeah
no it's names and the buttons okay so
you're just trying to say they're not in
the nfl
literally look i'm just saying is that
what you're saying let me check this
again buccaneers found them they're in
the south
and the bills are in the east i feel
like that would be allowed no but it's
east first like
i don't [ __ ] know i'm not even going
to pretend to know i just know those are
both east coast cities
so don't they have to play someone from
the west coast no i i hear what you're
saying loud and clear
so what's your what's your theory the
bills and the buccaneers yeah okay i
think they're going to make an exception
to the rule that's what i think
okay cool we'll see you in february 2022
for the bills versus the buccaneers
i think it's gonna be jets vs browns for
sure
i think it's actually gonna be jets
first giants
subway series yeah i don't think that
could happen no definitely not that's
why i said it it's a joke yeah but it
should be able to we're like
so athletic like look at your sweater oh
my god yeah go new york what does it say
ny ny it's cool sweater thank you it's
from joshua sanders the brand i wear
everything i got i've got a place in
order yeah you do said go new york go
new you go go new york go new york gotta
get to a sporting event
go who's stopping you your husband goes
all the time just ask him to be invited
but then he says like wanna go i'm like
no it's like a tuesday i've had a long
day no and it's like excruciating no and
then like what i have to do my hair like
it's a whole thing no those are that's
in a process yeah okay next story
a little content news house of the
dragon teaser shows the first footage of
the new game of thrones prequel series
that is set 200 years before game of
thrones house of the dragon is based on
george rr martin's fire and blood and is
set 200 years before the events of game
of thrones as part of the hbo max europe
launch event hbo max dropped the first
teaser for the series it's set to
premiere next year and it's all about
house targaryen they're in power during
the haunting teaser which offers the
first official footage from the show so
200 years before we're not going to know
literally anyone no but you'll know last
names yeah for example we have targaryen
we have a high tower
is that who's hightower i don't [ __ ]
know we know them another targaryen
another hightower valerian that sounds
like someone
miss area
i just can't get excited about things
that are happening in another year
i know like you know how much is going
to happen to me
it's good to have things to look forward
to but then but then it's like okay i
get excited for something in a year and
then when it comes out i don't even
watch it jackie i couldn't like agree
more to you enhance it i'm not just
gonna say ben special i was just gonna
say did you ever watch ben platt's
netflix special nope nope nope you're
really missing out it's so premium it's
too emotional
that's true it's too emotional i just
can't go there i feel that you know you
can't access that portal of your heart
right now i just can't like it's just
how do you then close it it's
i'm good i'm good on where i'm at i feel
bad um also like i keep seeing this
promo for this new sean peacock uh the
lost symbol which is based on the book
by dan brown who wrote da vinci code
every single time i
walk past it i'm like i'm going to watch
it and i literally never remember
no that's why people have to stop
announcing things so far in advance like
if i can't have it in the next three
months i really don't want to know about
it until then no i'm sure even when like
the new legally blonde movie comes out
like i'm not gonna even see it because
well
that's also just like us being real with
ourselves like what newly done movies
going to be terrible yeah but we love it
like
but it will be bad it will not even
become close to the level of
levels of iconicism that the first two
came in it's just really crazy that like
with all the money talent effort in the
world like there's just no possible way
it could be good yeah and i think it's
more of
a psychological thing like
it's not that they could have hired a
better writer and gotten a better script
it's been decaying it's going to be
amazing it's just impossible yeah no
it's true it's science
we don't make up the rules speaking of
content are you ready for our fifth and
final story
the final story
[Music]
not my best work but no i liked it i
liked it oh sorry no is it the fifth and
final story that's brought to you by
ship station holy [ __ ] holy ship
holy ship station is that possible yes
the holidays are coming up and if you're
selling anything online it's time to
prepare for the busiest time of year
between growing your business managing
inventory and juggling orders you've got
a lot to go to do this holiday season
and make shipping the easiest part of
your day with shipstation
figuring out the best way to ship your
orders can be frustrating and confusing
so ship station makes it quick easy and
convenient you can easily import orders
from any of your sales channels automate
just about any shipping task and spend
less time sorting through orders and
more time doing what you do best
shipstation integrates all selling
channels into one simple dashboard so
you can seamlessly connect carriers
print shipping labels and get products
out the door fast and over a hundred
thousand sellers are using shipstation
with their business so they can't be
wrong they're perfect for small
businesses and they have rates that are
even usually reserved for fortune 500
companies it's never too early to start
prepping for the holiday rush so get a
head start with shipstation our
listeners can use offer code toast to
get a 60 day free trial just in time for
the holidays that's two months of
stress-free holiday shopping for free
just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top and enter code toast ship
station make ship happen
love it okay our fifth and final story
is some
industry news big news the international
alliance of theatrical stage employees
has voted to go on strike have you been
seeing this no the iatsc members voted
to authorize a strike with over 98
percent support
signaling overwhelming support for its
union battles with studios over two
expiring contracts as widely its sc
members have voted to authorize an
industry-wide strike strike this marks
the first authorization of a nationwide
strike in the union's history so for the
past few weeks i've been seeing like
stuff on social media uh broadway actors
no these are everyone behind the scenes
in hollywood so it's oh uh lighting
we're always talking about lighting
crews
makeup costs i thought of some costume
designers okay so they've been um talk
that vote just took place and they
authorized the strike nine with 98 of
eligible members voting to strike so
this is going to affect all content
production what are they striking for
what do they want they want better
working conditions better hours they
want weekends they want meal breaks they
want better meal breaks
you don't get meal breaks
that's like that's what they're asking
for because they don't get those things
right now and the conditions these are
not conditions no they can work under
anymore they are saying
so this is going to bring things to a
halt in hollywood and this is the
largest strike of its kind but it does
remind me do you remember when the
writers strike the writers strike of
course when every show that we loved was
just no longer on because of the
writer's strike desperate housewives
yeah i feel like gossip girl um
so that was a crazy time i think this is
going to have like
similar effects at minimum that's so
crazy i do remember the writer's strike
that was like a pivotal time in my life
like and i needed the television and it
wasn't there for me yeah
so
yeah this includes crew members
internationally including
cinematographers operators grips editors
costumers and writers assistants among
others so when you go on strike who are
you striking against like the studios
the man yeah like the like
yeah the the head honchos like the
harvey weinstein types
well former harvey weinstein guys the
studio heads yeah i would imagine
that's crazy gotta love an organized
strike you know gotta go on strike never
been on what are you gonna strike for
world peace okay good luck i you know i
remember watching confessions of a
teenage drama queen when i was a kid and
she went on hunger strike even though
she was like secretly ordering pizza and
hiding it under her bed it's so you and
i was like i want to go on a hunger
strike but then i was like too hungry
yeah i don't think that's going to be
your protest method of choice no but i
think i could go on like a a vow of
silence [ __ ] no i could go honestly
i could go on a showering strike
no
no uh you will smell me and then you
will listen to what i have to say and
meet my demands no it has to be
something that affects you but like you
don't care if you don't shower that
doesn't make it a powerful strike no i
wouldn't care i wouldn't care after a
few years basically nobody else cares
like we could all just be away from you
really try i'll follow you we could all
be away from you we can lock you out
okay fine i think it would backfire but
why do i have to suffer in a strike
you just do
i don't think that's right i think that
you do then why would anyone go on a
hunger strike
that i don't understand
but when lola did it in confessions of a
teenage drama queen was because her
mother was obviously worried she would
starve to death yeah she was like
hurting her mother so people have to be
like concerned like people have to care
for you no i don't think so because like
let's say this union
like
the people making movies they don't
really care
about the well-being of no but if none
of these people will work they can't
make their movies i bet you the people
making movies will go find other people
to do the jobs i don't know under their
shitty conditions that's so hollywood
potentially they could but it's like a
hundred and fifty thousand
people well
times are tough people are going to be
accepting jobs that they might not
normally accept i'm sure it's conditions
they might not normally accept but
there's a labor shortage
that is throughout the country so i
don't have a sick labor shortage if they
could get people to work i just know
hollywood's like not gonna help the
little people you know no but they'll
have to reach some sort of agreement if
they want the show to go on well i hope
that everyone gets what they
asked for yeah
um okay well that was the past five
stories i feel as though you kind of
needed to know that there were they were
varied and i feel as though you needed
to know them i do also you're going to
want to know why your show isn't on
right right when there's no new episode
of riverdale yeah so we have to your
toasters and i have a major exciting
announcement about our third deer
toasters which i'll get to we have an
update from the girl who found adult
diapers in her husband's closet
do you remember i do but you know it
really is crazy how i have such a strong
memory yet some of your these deer
toasters evade me and i saw last week
there's like a conspiracy going on in
the toaster that we're recycling that we
are recycling deer toaster submissions
and maybe like some of them are similar
but i feel like if anybody would have
would feel like these are feeling so
familiar it'd be us no first of all i
don't even feel like they're familiar
we're not recycling i just think after
doing this episode that we did on
patreon last week we've all married the
same man so we're bound to have some of
the same problems you know but it was
like a bridesmaid thing like they swore
that we already did that but like i feel
like we would know first of all we're
not intentionally recycling so we're not
recycling we get so many submissions no
i know so like
it's a conspiracy against us and i just
want to say like
i
should we're
we're not nefariously doing it if it
were being done if it were being done
accidentally somehow
i think we would realize but it's
important to know there's absolutely
nothing nefarious going on no there's
nothing new that's going on but if you
want to go through every episode and try
and prove your point that we've read
verbatim the same deer toasters twice oh
yeah i'll listen to those facts yeah
i'll listen to facts okay so you ready
yeah dear toasters first off
congratulations to jackie o on the bed
bag you will be an amazing mom to this
little boy and him and all of your
future children are so blessed to have
you as a mom oh my that's so sweet
claudia i love you
and good luck on any upcoming projects
good luck with your period
no good luck on your upcoming projects
and tour you'll do so amazing you are
such an inspiration oh my god i [ __ ]
love this girl
here it goes my fellow big breasted
women help i need a breast lift and a
reduction at 20 21 years old my saggy
boobs are something that truly make me
want to cry every time i look in the
mirror at them otherwise i believe i'm a
pretty confident person like i said i'm
only 21 and these huge things grew on my
chest when i was literally 10
and 10 years old so due to that and
probably genetics my nipple my nipples
face the floor
i'm not laughing i have staggy boobs too
so like i can laugh see
no but like my nipples
i'm loving with you i really am
okay i went so eagerly to one plastic
surgeon consultation where they did a
whole bit of examining me and answering
questions and agreed that i'm a good
candidate for the procedure however my
last question i asked
truly broke my heart breastfeeding when
you get a breast lift you are no longer
able to breastfeed this is so sad to me
because i know how important the health
benefits of breastfeeding are and how
bonding it is to mom and pepe i'm a
newborn care specialist and
i work closely with moms and babies and
i see the benefits of breastfeeding
every day as soon as the surgeon told me
this i went from willing to book the
surgery for this coming december to
becoming firm on waiting 15 years until
i'm done having kids this appointment
was in june and now i'm back on the
train
saying screw my future kids immunity and
brain development i need new titties
this girl's funny
i'm pretty sure i've heard jackie
mention before how she would get some
work done to her titties after kids and
i just know as women with large boobs
you probably know all the struggles yes
do i get the surgery and stop being
scared to take my shirt off in front of
not only guys but also just my
girlfriends when we're all getting
changed and aside from my other people's
opinions do i get the surgery so i can
look myself in the mirror and not want
to cry or do i step vanity aside and
have what's what's in the best interest
of my future kids breastfeeding can also
be a journey so what if i don't get the
surgery there's other complications and
i don't even end up being able to
breastfeed the kids that i do have what
if due to my saggy titties
these girls hilarious wait
what if do
what if due to my saggy titties i can't
even find a man that thinks i'm
attractive enough to have kids with me
help a sister out please and any
toasters that have had similar
worries please feel free to start a
conversation in the toast after dark
group to help me make a decision with
love a toaster whose next entry is going
to be asking for ideas on how to make
enough money to afford the surgery lol
okay this is so relatable by the way i
think about this all the time so [ __ ]
relatable and i think about this all the
time i never
before i'm where i'm at now like i never
called and made an appointment or
anything it was always just something
that i knew that like yes of course i
would like to have my big fake titties
right now but like i have to wait until
after i have kids same i made the piece
that like i will not be able to get my
titties lifted and shrunk until the
children are born so like i've made
peace with that a long time ago i made
peace with it a long time ago too and it
definitely hinders things in your life
like i can't wear kylie swift
i can't do a jumping jack for a
multitude of reasons
you can get a good sports bra no yes
jackie i'm telling you i cannot do a
jumping jack you know what you're doing
for you right now show you because of
your breasts yeah
they knocked me right in the face
get up let's see really i'm gonna do a
full j well you're not wearing a sports
bra
well even with a sports bra i'm saying
okay well she didn't mention anything
about jumping jacks okay she said that
you know like for sharing personal
anecdotes aesthetics sure no but i think
there are certain things but like you
get a good bra check out dominique go
down to orchard street by the way if you
like or soma no next time you're in no
no no next time you're in new york you
go to orchard street corset google it
yeah you go there you go into the back
room the woman takes a look at your
breasts and gives you the perfect bra
for you that should help you in the
clothes department yeah okay so that's
just a fun trick of the trade for the
big breasted women um and so you're
feeling insecure about like taking your
top off around your girlfriends yeah
that doesn't happen for me yeah no also
i feel like
as much as your insecurities are valid
i'm not like trying to doubt um i just
feel like maybe you're 21 so like you're
still a little young like i stopped
changing in front of my friends a while
ago like yeah and when i was in high
school
who turns around like and i'm sorry
maybe my friends talk about me behind my
back but i don't [ __ ] care well i
just want to say i was never that girl
like no matter how big or small i was
like i was always comfortable but now
it's just like we're a little too grown
for that like it's not even about
insecurity it's about like i have a
husband like what am i doing yeah i feel
that and so then the other thing that
you had said was like you're worried
about someone loving you with your boobs
but like i feel like for a man a big
titty is a big titty jackie and you know
what i actually think of a better chance
of fun catching a man with your big
titty than with like post um like if you
wanna like because the boob that i would
get would it's furrowed it's a fashion
booth it's a fashion move it is not a
man's boob yeah by the way so like we
see women see like saggy nipples boys
they're like boobs like they literally
do not care about like the way the the
way in which they fall like they just
are excited to be in the presence of
breath so i wouldn't worry about that
hindering your dating life at all but
like it does feel like there's like a
deep insecurity inside of you that like
you think that the surgery would fix and
i like totally hear that as someone
who's had many procedures done like i
don't know i just feel like if you want
to get the surgery like
kids are born on formula and they're
totally fine like yeah i agree you can
do both i don't think it's life or death
there are plenty of people who went on
to be concert pianists who drank formula
i agree and that's what i was gonna say
next like on the flip side you know
plenty of people don't breastfeed who
even haven't had to make this choice or
don't breastfeed for very long and what
if you know
surgery and it doesn't work out
regardless so
it's a lot of pressure to put on
yourself about 21 like
i think you could just get the surgery
i don't know i think you could just get
the surgery i just personally like i'm
pretty much in the same boat as you and
i same and i'm gonna wait till after
yeah and she's also like a prenatal
specialist like that's what she does for
work so she knows really a lot about the
benefits of breastfeeding i don't know
you also just like gotta live your life
yeah and i mean how nice would it have
been to be in like 21 wearing kylie swim
and like having perky little bro oh
triangle bathing suit sure yeah oh
bathing suit from target sure yeah
borrow my friend's bathing suit sure
yeah no like
i don't know i kind of like love that
experience for you i don't know i'm
really i would support you either way i
know that's not helpful i know i will
support you either way as well it's not
helpful but you also don't need to
decide right now yeah that's true like
you could do it in a year yeah
totally maybe try orchard street first
okay we have two more one is a
submission and one is an update and it
is brought to you by ready slim
we've been feeling amazing we have more
energy we feel lighter and we're getting
great sleep feeling super refreshed
every morning thanks to the ready slim
detox teas ready slims detox teas are
made with high quality 100 organic herbs
that gently boost your metabolism and
help digestion while also reducing
bloating and gas we've added it to our
healthy lifestyle and we already feel a
few pounds lighter their detox teas are
made with no fillers no additives and no
laxatives so they're safe to drink daily
the best part of ready slam is how it
aids in weight loss plus it's keto
friendly say hello to a better brighter
you and right now for a limited time you
can save 25 on your first order of ready
slim's 28-day detox tea kit plus get a
free collapsible water bottle go to
readyslim.com toast that's
r-e-a-d-y-s-l-i-m.com
toast to save 25 on your first purchase
of ready slim's 28 day detox tea kit
plus a free collapsible water bottle
readyslim.com toast okay
next up
hey hey
jack and claude a fellow new york city
toaster here there has been absolutely
breaking news in my life that i'm in
dire need of advice on
on behalf of my best friend nicole since
middle school my best friend let's call
her nicole for confidentiality sake has
been in a relationship with her
boyfriend for six plus years they met in
college while he was a senior and she
was a freshman she got the impression at
first that he was a playboy but has
never had any suspicions or doubts until
this past weekend when she received a dm
on instagram from a burner account
telling her that her boyfriend has been
cheating on her nicole immediately
freaked out and told me and then
confronted her boyfriend he initially
denied deny denied the entire thing
until the guilt must have eaten him
alive and he admitted it all to make
matters even worse they are about to
move in together for the first time this
weekend as they've been doing long
distance for years as he lives four
hours away nicole is absolutely
distraught and doesn't know what to do
because they already signed the lease
and have some things moved in she has
only told me as her true bestie but she
hasn't
told any of her college friends or even
her mom and sister
as they would immediately banish in from
the family i really loved nicole's
boyfriend so i am enraged and very upset
to hear this news i can only offer her
so much advice but obviously this is a
very dicey situation as timing makes
everything worse would love to hear your
fabulous advice sincerely a sad toaster
who is dying on the inside for her best
friend uh you know apartments make
things like so complicated but they're
not moved in yet also like i know that
um cheating is cheating but like did he
drunkenly make out with a girl at the
bar is he carrying on a years long
affair yeah we do need more information
on what the actual incident was because
it does make a difference cheating is
cheating but like i do believe like
no i'm sure it's bad because like
someone had to make a burner account
like someone felt compelled to tell her
and he lied for so long and it's not
like he did something bad he felt guilty
he came to her so it's not good
even if they want to work things out
they should not move in together while
they work it out he can move into the
apartment and pay your rent
and as you know penance for what he
did and she can you know stay with you
or stay in her old apartment whatever um
but
if she moves in with him right now like
of course that will mean that they will
stay together he will have learned
nothing yeah paid no consequences and it
will happen again
honestly that was fire advice like i
don't think i would have come up with
anything better like he has to take on
the burden of the apartment and the
financial burden like he's the one who
ruined this relationship because
otherwise everything would be fine you
guys would be living in your fabulous
apartment splitting the rent but no he
had to go and be an [ __ ] so
that and also the thing with cheating
obviously cheating is terrible
but i feel as though if i were ever
cheated on the cheating would bother me
but what would bother me maybe even more
is like the lying straight to my face to
sneaking around and like being capable
of having like two lives like that would
bother me
scare me even more like the fact of like
him having sex with someone else so like
there's a lot to work through and it's
not gonna get worked through right now
and i don't think working through it
while living in a new apartment together
is the best way to do it because you're
just digging yourself in deeper and
making it harder to leave if that's what
you really end up needing to do yeah
don't let her move in with him let her
stay with you and
this is his problem he's he [ __ ] the bed
and he has to clean it up and pay the
rent yeah that's just my opinion agreed
okay finally the one we've all been
waiting for update from the girl who
found adult diapers in her husband's
closet
good
morning jackie and claudia thank you for
eating my email almost a year ago yes i
loved eating it
i wanted to provide you all with an
update so much has happened to me in the
last year after finding boxes of adult
diapers hidden in our home i confronted
my husband about it and i was shocked
and heartbroken when he explained to me
that he has been hiding this part of his
life with me for years
i wonder what our advice was well i
think maybe we thought it was like kinky
like oh he has been wearing diapers
since he was a child into and into his
adult life he is currently 32 years old
truly heartbroken and devastated i have
since left my husband i tried to
understand where he was coming from and
be there to support him but i couldn't
get over the fact that he lied to me for
so many years so he's just um
like
i'm not sure like she just said he's
been wearing diapers since he was a
child and into his adult life he's
currently 32 years old so i guess he
just never stopped wearing diapers
because
she just wait i tried to understand
where he was coming from and be there to
support him but i couldn't get over the
fact that he lied to me for so many
years as crazy as it sounds it wasn't
even the diapers as much as him lying to
me for so long that's what i just said
it's never the crime it's always the
cover up yeah and like you can say like
he's not potty trained and for some
reason
sorry
i don't think you call it potty train
when the person's an adult but yes okay
but no but whatever it is like he can't
control his bladder that could be like
uh i've not heard of that but that could
be like a health thing for sure like you
love someone through that like it's warm
that's not something like i'm sorry
that's not a deal breaker no the lying
sneaking around makes you jump what else
are they 100 and like that there's this
big wedge between you it's like did i
ever really know you if this is
literally something that you do every
single day and you didn't feel like you
could share it with me so wait there's
more since separating life has honestly
been so great my ex and i decided to
remain friends and i'm there for support
if he ever needs someone to talk to he
has also since come out as gay which is
something he has been burying his entire
life and he is so much happier being his
true self that's fabulous i'm so happy
for him as for me oh my god i have
chills i actually ended up
sorry wait i lost my spot as for me i
actually ended up falling in love with
my best friend i confided in him during
the situation and he has been so helpful
in my healing we've been so close since
high school and the only man i've ever
fully been my true self with and knows
everything about me it's the healthiest
happiest relationship i've ever been in
we just got a house together and a puppy
and i got a new job it's crazy to think
about how much life has changed in one
year and i want to thank you so much for
giving me the courage to confront my ex
about his diapers because i don't know
that i ever would have and we both would
be living a lie for who knows how long
thanks girlies love you so much oh my
god there's so much to unpack here he
came out as gay
she fell in love with her best friend
she got a house a dog a man a job
oh my god we're literally changing lives
that is so beautiful
and you know
with the diapers thing it's like
i still don't understand why like if it
was a health issue or he was like
i don't know
but
and this is kind of what we were saying
before like it's never just the one
thing like there's always more
underneath it's a smoking gun yeah so
i think and that's what we always say
here when it comes to relationships like
really
talking about it can never steer you
wrong i know but it's so funny because
like i don't take that advice i bury
everything unless it's like my
philosophy is i bury it
and then if if i'm having if i'm not
having success burying it then i bring
it up but sometimes i can bury something
and i will literally forget about it and
it's not like it like bottles up and
festers at the time me like someone will
remind me like remember and i'm like oh
[ __ ] yeah no i bury hatchets but i keep
maps of where i put them that's toxic
that's really bad like no die barry
hatchets but i keep them up where i put
them no sometimes i like genuinely
forgot that i was upset about that thing
and that's good that means it didn't
require conversation that means you're
healing yeah nature is healing but then
sometimes i it's like like eating you up
eating me up and then it's conversation
time that's nice and healthy but that
works for me everybody's different no to
be honest like i'm very much
i do take my own advice in this
particular situation there's nothing
that goes on in my relationship that
bothers me that i do not verbalize like
i'm almost a little too communicative
i'm a pick your battle sort of girl no i
just don't like conflict so it has to
really
really be eating at me for me to want to
engage in confrontation no i'm a
pleasure to be married to i always have
something to say that's funny yeah um
well that was very exciting that is
really exciting really not expecting all
of that no me neither
see this is why we love updates no
matter how long ago we read your prompt
this has been a year and she had so much
to update us on so if we've read your
prompt recently email us deartoasters
gmail.com with an update we would love
to hear from you and if you just have a
problem you want our help with dear
toasters gmail.com that is the email
that is our show that is the final show
of the week you guys i'm headed out
we're back on monday and tuesday of next
week with podcasts we're back on tuesday
we're back on tuesday of next week with
a podcast only episode i'm back in
studio on wednesday yes and new episode
of the redhead shops thursday so if
you're looking for some content head
over there and as always we have premium
episodes on all of our tnn shows we've
got the snatcher we've got mood we've
got caviar dreams we've got our patreon
we've got our patreon so really there is
enough content to go around
just make sure you space it out right
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast fast
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart with your cast box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us morning tell sleep if i
start our view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are if you made it
to the end of this episode
congratulations you're true toaster a
part of the society season two
uh and to let us know that you have made
it to the end of this episode why don't
you drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram pic perhaps the emoji of
is there a diaper
no i don't think so maybe the poop emoji
mm-hmm no that's right yeah um oh maybe
it was diapers for poop
as opposed to for what p
what about why not both i guess both i
was just only thinking about p no i was
thinking about poop
um
okay well now that we said it let's just
do the poop emoji
poop emoji we love you guys have a great
day and we'll see you on wednesday and
tuesday of next week bye